ground report com is a citizen news
reporting site that allows anyone to
publish their own articles videos and
photos to a global audience and earn a
revenue share based on their traffic all
of our work is vetted by our volunteer
editors and you can reach an audience of
millions some of our big scoops have
been the Beijing Olympics the Mumbai
terrorist attacks Taliban activity in
Pakistan and then even in our backyard
covering Obama's elections through
through the eyes and words of regular
Americans we have 5,000 contributors on
the ground who regularly submit stories
every day
building ground report space has been
completely deliberate it's not a typical
internet startup where you just want to
get as many people as possible we're
looking for a very sophisticated digital
reporter who is able to convey what's
going on from the ground level so we
want two things we want them to be savvy
enough to use the digital reporting
tools but we also want them to be on the
ground hyperlocal to report exactly on
what they're witnessing in their
immediate vicinity vicinity they don't
we don't want someone who's sitting at a
desk in New York writing about Pakistan
we want a pakistani lawyer who was
protesting the day before to be writing
about pakistan so I've been very
deliberate and doing outreach to
journalistic bloggers professional
journalists retired or students in
training and then also nonprofits a lot
of people who happen to be witnessing
some of the world's most urgent issues
and are there in the ground but lack the
proper platform to get the word out
the vetting process really happens at
the report level so anyone can sign up
and report immediately and submit
reports articles videos etc for
publication but it won't go live until
one of our editors takes a look at it so
anyone is allowed to do that that way we
don't miss the big scoops we open up the
doors in that way but we need that layer
of approval for it to really make sure
that it's up to our standards and to be
able to stand behind our brand name
we're happy to serve both of those
audiences I mean one of the biggest
things about hyper local news that is
covering covering issues and events at a
level that's even more granular than the
city level is that most of those topics
are really most interesting to the other
people who are living in that area so of
course a lot of ground reports coverage
that's that specific will be interested
interesting to people in those spaces
but on the other end we have people for
instance American audiences and just
audiences all over the world who want to
know what's really happening in the
world who recognize that the
international media is not serving its
goal to really inform the public and so
they're interested in these stories too
and they rely on ground report to sort
of aggregate and vet all of this
information that's coming in and give
you a real picture of okay here's what
people on the ground experiencing this
event feel about it here's what the real
story is
the only thing that we mean with the
original content policy is it means you
must have the rights to distribute
whatever content you post on ground
report so we're very happy to work with
people who are reposting from their blog
or from independent news sources in fact
there's some of our most valuable
partners what we don't allow is
copyright infringement or plagiarism
which actually is pretty rampant on a
lot of citizen journalism platforms and
that's because our biggest value at
ground reporting we've made our name on
this is by having sophisticated original
content and original reporting and that
also helps us to pursue a syndication
model can't syndicate other people's
content it's also something that doesn't
really serve us in the end and it's not
the kind of contributors we're looking
for so we're happy to adhere to that
policy
I would actually say that the opposite
that I think in recent years we've seen
an explosion in the democratization of
the media in terms of people having
these tools the tools to produce content
or intelligent news reporting all over
the world the people who have internet
access has completely exploded and the
people who have the ability to
distribute so previously it really was
not a democracy and I don't think anyone
would have pretended it was in which you
had a few large media organizations that
control the means of distribution so
whatever they said would become the
dominant narrative now what we have with
the internet is everything is accessible
and the democratization is there and
ground report sort of serves in a middle
space which is we don't want to be
complete anarchy we do want to add some
value by applying some of these really
important journalistic practices to
gathering vetting and distributing the
news but at the same time we want to
make sure everyone has an opportunity to
offer their views and whatever
documentation they have of recent events
so I think the trend is definitely going
in the right direction what we need now
is sort of this Midway filter that is
able to look at that information apply
filters apply betting so that it comes
out in a more intelligent sophisticated
manner where it actually has value to
the audience it's trying to serve
times the the vetting process can pose
entirely new challenges just because
maybe these systems have never been
applied to such local breaking news
events the other thing that's one of the
biggest challenges is basically a
learning curve to explain to regular
people and journalists alike especially
with professional journalists it's
difficult that they can post content
independently on their own will vet it
afterwards they you know people still
will be emailing articles to the site
saying is this all right they don't they
don't really understand that they can
just go ahead and publish it we want to
keep that ball rolling as quickly as
possible so it's educating people that
yes this is ok we want to encourage you
to sort of be be the master of your own
work and be entrepreneurial and and
we'll do the rest
I think that it's more important than
ever I think that first we need to
recognize that many of the people who we
consider to be professional journalists
may have no credentials at all may have
really earned their chops by working and
and and and expend building work
experience but that we certainly need to
reward entrepreneurial journalists I
think now more than ever it is very
important to be a journalist who is able
to innovate who is able to be
resourceful in a number of different
ways by using all of these new tools and
forms of media so I think that maybe our
idea of a traditional journalist that is
less important now but the professional
journalist is more important than ever
another thing that we try to do to
address this on ground report is that we
distinguish between being a professional
journalist and being completely neutral
and objective and being perhaps a
citizen reporter a regular layman but
being very transparent about your views
so we're focusing more on transparency
than neutrality to say okay maybe you do
have biases somewhere but at least if
you're expressing them on ground report
if you're pointing them out in your
profile it's okay if there is a if
there's a little disparity there
we're in the midst of our biggest
information revolution probably since
the printing press and yet we're seeing
a total breakdown of how the media is
going to be able to cover these events I
think that efforts that focus on hyper
local news gathering and citizen
reporting are going to be moving into
this space I think they really need to
learn from the lessons of vetting and
news gathering and holding holding all
reporters to high standards that we can
learn from the traditional media so i
think that there's there's a middle
ground there definitely what I think the
best thing the platforms and efforts
like ground report have to offer is we
show what can be achieved when you
really cut costs when you really remove
all of the bloat and you're able to just
get rid of the overhead and focus on
people who are already there so we have
an incredibly lean efficient economical
model that way that in fact is paying
for itself right now and we hope to just
scale that up and I think that if we can
begin to build models that start with
taking advantage of the incredible
resources of millions of people around
the world with all this power we can
start to build a model that will make
sense
and I think that the ground reports
revenue share system in many ways is
modeled on the way that microfinance
works and that is we're rewarding people
based on the fruits of their labor and
hopefully they can invest that further
and often people will or contributors
will write to me and say you know I got
this funding I was able to get you know
a better mobile phone or I was able to
get a better computer and now we're
going to create better reports and
they're very very passionate about it so
it's something that isn't important on
so many different levels and not even
just in the developing world people are
so amazed to be paid for their work
especially since the rule online is so
often that sites expect you to just give
your the content that you're creating to
them for free while they build a
business model off of it well we didn't
think that was really fair we also
thought the best way to attract the
people who are creating the best content
online which is a very very small
percentage of the people who are
engaging online is to reward them for
for what they're doing
I think it's certainly true that when
you're looking at the digital format we
have just begun to explore its potential
I mean we're still sort of recreating
newspapers on websites and that's that's
not really what it's built for I think a
couple of the biggest areas for
innovation or again Twitter which allows
for the most immediate fast-paced
real-time news updates it's a tool that
I use all the time and ground report to
stay in the loop on what the most recent
breaking news is you can often get
updates there before you can get on any
major news website but also to recruit
reporters who happen to be at those
locations it allows for really fast
interactions and iterations there on the
flip side there's no vetting and there's
no filtering of that sort in terms of
integrity especially when you're dealing
with sources you don't know on Twitter
so that's one problem the other spaces
is when you start to get into these new
forms of media so we've already seen
some really great innovation with photos
and photography online I think where
there's some of the next steps will be
with live streaming video ground report
TV launched its channel a couple of
years ago actually on the Moghuls
platform and it allows us to basically
cover live events with video using just
an internet connection and a laptop as
well as say a huge fox satellite truck
that that's costs you know hundreds of
thousands or millions of dollars and
that's what we did this past weekend at
the NASA shuttle launch for instance the
thing that we have to wait for there is
for the 3g network that's necessary for
all of our mobile devices to be able to
send information that quickly and it's
also still a technology that is limited
to people who have access to the
Internet in general so those are those
are a couple of the of the places but
when you look at things like the Nokia
you know and 95 and later models which
can allow you to stream video straight
from your phone to a website it's it's
pretty incredible what the potential
that could be for a citizen powered 24 7
News Channel
but we certainly want to serve what
people are really interested in and
clearly the global news category is is
much smaller than people are interested
in sort of you know entertainment news
but that's also a very very crowded
field I mean there are millions of
players in that field that are trying to
exploit that it's something that with
the right tone we would accept on ground
report but we're pretty focused on
making just building up our brand I mean
starting any kind of internet company
it's so difficult to define what you're
looking for in the beginning on ground
report anything was allowed people could
post any kind of content and after a
while it just it started to dissolve
what the brand was really about so we
need to stand behind that and say okay
we're about sophisticated global
reporting from professionals or vetted
by professionals or some combination of
the two what we are starting to do is to
expand into specific verticals so we
might not do entertainment just yet but
we might do something really gender
issues or we might start to do something
related to travel and this also has to
do some of the sponsors who are
interested in getting involved with our
work and we're definitely going in those
directions and we're looking to be a
little bit more niche a little bit more
granular in those spaces but still but
still keep our general structure
one of the stories that is most
incredible to me is that is the Taliban
activity in Pakistan ground report has
been covering this for a year and a half
we've been getting almost daily reports
of increased you know militant activity
in these areas we have a very we have a
very strong constituent base there
that's been reporting to us lots of
professional journalists and only just
now has the American media woken up to
the fact that okay we're in the midst of
a major crisis here but if if you'd
looked at ground report a year ago you
would have seen you would have seen all
of the indications that this was set to
happen I just mentioned that I was at
the NASA shuttle launch live streaming
with an inverse that satellite dish in
the laptop just enough stuff that you
could fit in a knapsack that was pretty
exciting some of the other breaking
stories that we've seen let's try to
think in in Zimbabwe we've been seeing
lots of signs of unrest we have a lot of
reporters there who are writing under
pseudonyms to protect their identity but
it will be anything from you know
there's mutiny among Mugabe 'he's
soldiers there they want to break away
to a general unrest among the public
things that wouldn't end up in a
newspaper in zimbabwe because people
could be an in danger but but that we're
very happy to publish and sort of
counter a call the disinformation out
there
we can't really take responsibility
because our model is not really giving
people assignments so much as allowing
them to publish their own work so in
contrast to something like Current TV we
don't send reporters and pay for them to
go places and equip them with all these
tools although we will sometimes give
people things like flip video cameras
etc we sometimes do outreach when
there's been a breaking event but it's
usually nothing that requires someone to
go to the scene of an event and we're
very cautious about listen your safety
is more important to us than anything
else so never compromise that in any way
will usually more take the event and say
okay what are people thinking about how
do people feel about this how have you
been affected personally because that's
that's what sort of takes takes the
event and and stops you from sort of
glazing over saying this is some big
international issue and saying wow
there's some emotional engagement there
that's that's a real person who's
experiencing it
absolutely that's that also plays into
the the safety question because you say
oh are you worried about people being in
Pakistan okay these are people who have
grown up in Pakistan and they're
probably the safest that anyone will
ever be because they have relationships
there so again that's exactly the kind
of mobile or digital or even citizen
reporter that we try to recruit is
people who already have their own
networks who are already very connected
in that region are able to speak to
people in decision-making capacities at
the at the head of any event that takes
place or able to sort of tell us here's
exactly what you know the head of the
police is saying here's what the head of
the local political party is saying and
maybe they are even part of those
political parties etc these these are
the kind of people who will really be
able to connect us in a way that a
foreign a foreign reporter never could
or foreign correspondent the other the
other side of that is they can get an
answer out of these people that may be
much more honest much more revealing
than than than a foreign reporter
our goal for working with developing
countries is more to acknowledge what
the situation is with their technology
and and sort of take advantage of that
in the best way we can so for instance
in a lot of these countries the mobile
phone penetration is enormous so instead
of pushing them to do live streaming
video which is basically impossible
because they won't have an internet
connection that's fast enough will push
them to contribute via mobile phone or
or two to post to post reports that way
so we'll really focused on the mobile
capacities so when basically every
region in the world there's different
ways that we interact in different tools
that we encourage people to use
it was inspired over a long period of
time first by my work as a political
intern at the US mission to the United
Nations which I initially wanted to work
directly for the UN but instead got an
internship at the State Department which
ultimately was probably more access than
I ever could have dreamed of in any role
because of the incredible sort of
influence of the US and so I was
reporting daily on security council
sessions which are confidential closed
sessions basically all the top
ambassadors of the ten members of the
Security Council and watching firsthand
as foreign policy was made and basically
the biggest issues in the world were
debated and decided here's what we're
going to do the Security Council is
really the the decision-making arm of
the UN the only one that really carries
weight and is able to carry out their
actions the issues at the time some of
the issues that I was covering was Haiti
the assassination of former lebanese
prime minister hariri and the Darfur
crisis was really at its peak it was
really getting really bad and there was
one day when then a secretary general
kofi annan came into the council and
addressed the council and basically and
basically sort of begged all the members
to do something he said it is completely
out of control and and it really struck
me and the thing that really bothered me
was the fact that even though the US had
been one of the first to call it out as
genocide the Darfur crisis we didn't
really pledge anything beyond saying
that we didn't pledge any concrete
action which if we had knowing the
dynamics of the Security Council our
allies probably would have responded ten
or hundred fold in supporting us and
that was something that was something
that really troubled me one of the
quotes that Kofi Annan used at the time
was that the role of the UN is not to
bring humanity up into heaven but to
prevent it from descending into hell and
that was what was happening there so I
ended the internship at the term when it
was done and it was a fantastic
experience but I said I need to be in a
space where there's more innovation
where things are more dynamic because
there was just so much bureaucracy sort
of holding back that kind of innovation
and I went to work for limewire which is
a file sharing platform which is totally
different
but what was interesting to me was there
i was helping them relaunch their
websites and learning all about these
really cheap but very powerful
publishing tools and i realized we could
start to address this problem that had
really plagued me at the UN which is
that we can allow people to really know
what's going on in the world because if
the public is more informed they can put
more pressure on their governments to
make responsible policy decisions and I
feel very strongly about that I do
believe that and so the idea I had was
instead of having these dry wire reports
why don't we let people who are actually
they're experiencing these things these
terrible atrocities or these wonderful
events to in their own voice report the
news or take a photo or publish a video
and will aggregate it all together and
we'll bet it with our editors and we'll
make sure that it's that we're giving
everyone a chance to share their voice
and reach this global audience and that
was that was how the idea for ground
report was born the funny thing is that
I I had always wanted to do a job where
I can and I still do where I can do both
international relations and and
technology and web stuff so I'm sort of
like a geek on one end but I majored in
history on the other end and fought
three or four years ago none of these
jobs exist existed and now of course all
these projects are exploding all over
the internet and ground report was just
in its infancy when this happened so
it's I basically made it up because it
didn't exist
it's hard to sort of judge what the
exact impact has been on public
awareness because how do you measure
public awareness of an idea so ground
report has certainly brought attention
to a lot of issues that people otherwise
never would have heard of but it's hard
to see how that translates into
something at the other end we've had a
lot of nonprofits for instance writing
under the name of their nonprofit
published reports and later on they were
eventually able to you know gain key
legislation one interesting example is
my my hometown of Dobbs Ferry was able
to get a historical distinction from
from Congress for being one of the sites
that George Washington visited on on you
know on his campaign and they had
published the the local historian had
published numerous research reports and
updates proving this so those are a
couple of examples of you know I don't
know if there's a direct causation there
but certainly certainly contributed then
we have other issues where we've seen
more humanitarian based results that are
really wonderful so for instance we have
a we have a an Afghani reporter who
reported on a young woman about I think
16 or 17 who was attacked by her husband
who she was married to through an
arranged marriage I think he was in his
60s or 70s and she was disfigured and
she was burned with acid and it was
really terrible and unfortunately this
is a fairly common story but because it
was on ground report because it was on
an english-language source the reporter
was contacted by an aid organization
that ended up covering all of the
medical medical costs and I didn't even
hear about this until like a month after
it took place and I and I noticed
because the reporter had put the
follow-up report on ground report and so
the other thing we do is we just we
allow people to connect amongst
themselves and not just pushing one
overall agenda but we allow all these
little connections to happen that in
little ways help help to improve society
I think the biggest thing that I've
learned because I was coming at this not
from a media or journalism background I
was coming at Ground report from a
diplomacy and international relations
and a technology background is the
incredible importance of the trusted
human network so we can create these
algorithms that build wonderful looking
virtual newspapers but without the human
input it really doesn't work because you
can't get a computer to to put stories
together at least not yet in a way that
that really works and it's also
something that translates to your
community and I mean not just your
audience but you're contributing
community so if we just have when we at
Ground report just had this algorithm
that was choosing the stories and
publishing it wasn't really enough once
we built this team of volunteer
Wikipedia style editors who could go in
any piece of content the suddenly the
platform felt like it was alive and it
really translated in the behavior of our
contributors who took themselves much
more seriously they realize this is this
is an active thing and there are people
on the other end or really care about
what we're doing so i would actually
take sort of the opposite slant of what
so many of my peers say and say it's the
human network is so incredibly important
that we need to really focus on on that
aspect and also a lot of a lot of the
things that go along with that like
vetting and fact-checking
you